no no
listen listen yeah anybody missed it but
now they have to see that i
absolutely like that um that was the
wrong way of living
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hotbox and i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson
mike we got a very special guest man
well with the
let's check this out let's see what
they're talking about vincent bragg
ceo founder of concretes yes sir
great organization great company
why don't you introduce your people
and tell us about concretes absolutely
so
concrete is essentially a advertisement
agency so we focus on marketing branding
pr things like that
i think the thing that makes us
different than any other agency out
there is we solely
employ incarcerated and formally
incarcerated how much they get paid
it depends on the project
sophisticated guys i know
it really just depends on the project
you know and the brand that we working
with with the budget or whatever so
um it's structured from a standpoint of
10
of the company is actually owned by the
network of incarcerated and formally
incarcerated so we profit share if that
means anything
and then also based on the ideas that
are given
they get there's a fee schedule for that
once we kind of narrow it down to like
five ideas
then they also there's another fee
schedule where those five ideas or those
five people get paid and then once we
get to the part that goes into
production
then they actually get a bonus for that
so
so yeah that's how they get paid it's
awesome man it's awesome
so i'm gonna just go to the yeah please
please so we got my man rick ricky coley
this is one of my brother's idea tom
with he's an original cop
he's from ricky south central yeah yeah
vince are you from l.a i am i'm from
watts okay
so we got joe nixon who is also the
co-founder
of concretes joey nixon
jelly nixon joe nixon from um south
central los angeles as well
awesome and then we also got tony welsh
who is our director of influence and
also our accounts manager
at concretes who's just
a queen within herself yeah says he's
just a queen
but go ahead i'm from detroit michigan
my name is tony wedge
i'm accounts manager for concrete yeah
she used to have
that big money so right yes
this is what we have in common we all
come from [ __ ] huh
really bad shitty places that we never
want to go back to her
i took a trip to see in brownsville mike
and i i don't want to go there anymore
no i understand where you come from yeah
they don't understand the car
something just they don't
like for us we never had a hero
but you are our hero because you come
from where we come from yeah and we
understand you and you lead with your
flaws and you i don't stop
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] is just brilliant
anything that i succeeded in is because
of my flaws yeah
you know [ __ ] my my floor that i don't
really like myself because i didn't come
from the right side of town i'm on
[ __ ]
products of prostitutes and pens and
[ __ ] and all that
yucky stuff that i love right
yeah so i can't love that stuff and be
the guy that i am because it's not good
for business but you know i miss that
guy though
we literally used to steal cable to
watch your fight yes
you know what i'm saying why are you
going to tell them don't push money
[Laughter]
whatever everybody can contribute man
i would steal it too like it was a treat
it was a treat for me to
to get a's and b's in order for my
mother and my father to give me mike
tyson's punch out
are you serious because that's something
that i wanted you know what i'm saying
you don't understand like
it was just and when we finally found
the code to play you without actually
getting there and you whooped our ass in
two seconds we like man i'm not [ __ ]
with mike
he didn't even let me get a punch i wish
i could um understood that part of my
life that part of my life is just
don't exist yeah because you were living
yeah the um the the [ __ ] the
punch-out [ __ ]
or nintendo the fight you know you just
think that um
imagine what it would be like to watch
yourself fight in life
you know i never could understand that
being in the ring and i understand i saw
everybody i heard everybody yelling i
heard my friends voices and stuff but i
wasn't a part of that
right it's all about me that moment but
i'm not a part of it isn't that
something
isn't that weird it's all about me but
i'm not a part of it what
i want to experience what they
experienced what made them happy what
made them
want to be around me i want to know what
that feels like because i think being
around me is [ __ ]
i hate being around me so i want to want
what's the feeling that makes them want
to be around me i want to feel that
feeling
because i want to feel it because i want
to be around me everybody does that make
sense
winner though you are a champion people
want to be around
success and winning and you know when
you come from nothing and they see that
it's like man this mic man he went in
and
you know he come from the bottom and you
know that's like you know that's that
give us juice and energy you know what i
mean like
that made me want to go far i used to go
to the hoover gym and just try to
emulate what i've seen from you like
okay
you know and i got knocked out a couple
times you know what i'm saying i see
that
but you know it was just the fact that i
was able to just
had that drive and that's just because
we seen you know
we playing um punch out and we watching
the fights and
we know we're going to get some boxing
glyphs let's go fight in the backyard
you know what i mean so
you know it's funny when you hear a
perspective from somebody else
and you think what what you endure to
become that person
and it's nothing really what they're
talking about
imagine that's just from being um mike
tyson this guy got created from being
bullied
he's worried about somebody trying to
kill him always worrying about
protecting it's not being safe
imagine you guys know not being safe
[ __ ] coming
in the house all strange you know what
that's like
so um i say to myself all that came from
my shame and stuff my all set my
successes for my shame
isn't that where all my success comes
from my shame
my parents was in the right place can't
come from flawless though
who who who created that narrative like
it comes from
it can come from anything that does they
come from floors
yeah but this is where it gets tricky at
can we embrace those laws
a lot of us can't embrace who we are i
think that's the beauty of
what we do at concretes right like our
mission statement
our mission is to literally change the
stigma how society views people with
criminal history
but then also how do people with
criminal histories view themselves
so i founded this company on a belief
system that
creativity without opportunity is what
lead to criminality right
so where somebody might look at joe
nixon who
successfully robbed 27 banks as a bank
robber
i look at him as a strategist or someone
who might
look at ricky coley here as an ex-drug
dealer
i look at him as an entrepreneur and a
logistics expert how do you get
this from this communication exactly
right you look at somebody like tony
um who you know first off operated
at the highest level of of a drug empire
that
that we know today in our in our culture
and dealt with the money who dealt with
the relationships who
managed those relationships and made
sure things was in intact
that's a skill set that's that's
transferable
into this corporate arena right so like
i said we brought you a gift just to
kind of show you an example
of of the work that we do like so
my man he created a line called rich sex
and it's a luxury which sex
sex sex and cold is the thing tell me
about that
let's bust it out hey nobody brought me
a joint yet thank you a lot guys
i really got power here i'm really in
control
we're gonna put it out one by one for
you right yeah so right here
is uh the rich sex novelty gift box
hey man you got these [ __ ] little
joints man what are you
doing where's the blunt where's the
spliff at dude
you're killing me you're killing me on
the [ __ ] podcast the [ __ ]
the roach joint that might
come in that velvet bag well yeah it
looks like some really good
[ __ ] and i saw it to the cameras
all right show the camera protect your
to tell you all the instruction all the
ingredients now it's all plant-based
um it's all organic um all-natural
so what do i taste okay you don't taste
nothing
what you do you might not use condoms
but
[Laughter]
but they come with this is made in
germany it was formulated
it's a lubricant um it's a bodyguard
lubricant
i didn't use condoms when i was supposed
to use cars
and then right here we got the massage
oil and i have a cbd version that i
didn't bring but
this is a massage oil this is something
that you take on your vacation when you
want to be with your white i want to
just
party and have fun it's it's just a
complete setup of everything you need to
just
keep your playerism and your macking
going then here we go
we got this toy right here it's the
batman it's a copyright
[ __ ] yeah the top it lights up it got
different different speeds
so yeah
yes lord yeah okay because i realized
listen know what i realized and stuff
that um sometimes my ego is
not my reality i think that i'm the [ __ ]
i'm making somebody happy but really i'm
not
and then when i find it i'm not i feel
[ __ ] this is what you're gonna like
mike
what's that masturbation this is this
right here this is the enhancement
vitamin it's all natural products
ingredients everything all natural um
and that's going to keep that's going to
keep you
that's going to keep you popping for
that it's going to keep it cracking
about three days you can stop chill it's
gonna relax then when you get back ready
it's gonna go back hard it's gonna be
right there ready for you this thing
gonna be harder than you hit him and
then you know
i'm sure your house is big michael's i'm
sure you live in a big old house so
you got these wipes just in case you
don't feel like running to the bathroom
you can just
pop them anti-big chair wipes just in
case you don't want to run to the
bathroom you can just
clean it up that's what i mean here's
your candle and this is a moisturizer
candle so you can burn this
it's um it's beeswax coconut oil
and um one other ingredient apple
apricot
and it's all natural you know what i
mean and you can pour it
you got any sage any [ __ ] some instincts
you got any incense you'll need
instances with no without what i do got
dope mic that you don't like
if you don't mind this is the room
freshener so i can spray some of this
go ahead and uh yeah what i mean
you know you can keep this in your car
you can keep this in your wherever
you put it on your bed you put it on
your um you put it on use the body spray
and then good stuff right here no
absolutely yeah
and then these are unisex these are oils
all natural
essential oil that's the 100 all natural
um
there you go
oh and then i got you so
this right here is a body hand lotion
i can check that out that just stops
all natural everything this is a massage
oil
everything is organic it's natural i
love organic soaps
yes here it goes shower gel it's all
again
i mean you know i mean you know
you
so that's what the box but see like if
you want to like just have this at the
office
you know this is the big bottle of the
room freshener really
we brought that
so what is it that you're doing that she
loves so much man we just
being ourselves we
[Music]
we take created and take them put them
on steroids so
except we we harness the creativity we
harness the creativity
beyond them and behind bars so we focus
like every single person that's sitting
in here did time
i got hit with a conspiracy charge that
gave me 121 months of federal prison for
selling drugs
and you know this man he was huge in the
weeds space this guy
rob banks she was money laundering yeah
i'm saying hey listen right
i was in prison out here and i was free
in there um
so tell me so tell me this chap so was
it more
that controlled environment that
and and it didn't allow you to just be
might
if you had to follow rules and you
didn't have that structure besides when
you had to deal with customato or your
no i'm saying was that missing
no what was it no oh no
you see who i am out here
i'm a trillion times that in there
so you was running you was running the
yard oh
i had a girlfriend got my girlfriend
pregnant in the car it's just something
it's just i love that whole fact yeah oh
i read the books and yeah all right
i love my power with the power i had
that every night i go to my room and
what do you want to eat tonight
yeah yeah whatever we wanted we we did
whatever we wanted the cop the guys
would bring
women really it's just [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't deserve delivery i get mad at
myself i get jealous of myself i [ __ ]
want to break myself down i want to
hurt myself because i don't deserve that
if i got too much [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do i
think i am you ain't [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got all this [ __ ]
how you don't know about that part of
the game do you you don't know about
that part of the game the site game huh
you don't even know the [ __ ] we are but
we think we do i think we do
our only objective is really our purpose
is dying
life prepares us for death period and um
the meaning of life is willingness to
die
you know he just [ __ ] me up you just
threw me all the way
up that was profound control
you know you had to be when you when you
were in there you wanted to do something
to beat the system to beat it
well absolutely and um listen no one
else
baby go for take no no you're going to
go there go ahead no
you know we all did you know because i
did things that i just had to do
just to see that i could get away with
it because that's what i knew that was
the norm
of getting away with things but it
wasn't like after afterwards i was like
[ __ ] i'm ready to go
every day i was still ready to go but
every day i was finding something that i
could try to get away with
you know because we were addicted to
that our personalities my personalities
i was addicted to getting away with
things
a crime or that power you know but
that's how i did it yeah you just we all
did that time together
yeah i mean i'm talking about we had
lockers upon
lockers with food in it and some people
are in the laptops
[Music]
everybody in the cell 80 percent had my
food in that locker
i said go to him go to him go to him go
to him go to him
right so i mean i think it was also that
too was just controlling our environment
and and and really wanting to put
ourselves up there i didn't realize we
had more control than
we had up there in here we can get it we
could break the law in there we can get
we can't break the [ __ ] law out here
but we could break it in there that's
something
yeah i didn't i didn't realize how
insecure of a person i was until i had
to sit down
listen and that's more important than
having sex i'd rather be in there not
[ __ ] nobody
than having control to be out here and
[ __ ] everybody and having nothing
that's pretty heavy no that's not heavy
at all that's pretty simple yeah but
it's math for the rhythm i mean for me i
didn't
really get to know who i was until i
went to prison because you got all these
people telling you
you this you that they pumping you up
because of course they want something
from you so they're not giving you
the true essence of who you really are
they're just
um it's just all about manipulation and
when you get there and you by yourself
and you sit in there and you like damn i
got to figure me out i don't even know
who i am
like i thought i did but i didn't
because
i was getting false information the
whole time because all those people went
on with their life all the people he was
helping
doing things for those were the same
people that
made it and you like y'all tricked me no
you took yourself
exactly you were looking for their you
were looking for their what
their validation exactly your validation
is within you and that's why now i don't
give
zero [ __ ] no no that's the whole thing
you have to care no i care about no no
no
that word that you don't give a [ __ ] has
to disappear from your vocabulary
because now you're stuck now now that
you don't kill him or you can't grow
yeah
well you're going to go you're not going
to go to his debt no more
now that now that's your master because
you're not going towards that no more
that that prevents you from moving on
that stops you when you see that
that's what you say that whatever it is
that you say that made you say [ __ ] that
that stops you now yeah that's your
master yeah
i don't say [ __ ] nothing yeah i want it
all
yeah you know because life has a better
[ __ ] you hand
yeah i just didn't want i just what i
mean when i said that i just don't want
the fake
love no no no listen brother this is
what you should you know
in prison words mean a lot be careful
what you say know what you're saying
don't say nothing by accident yeah
because that's what they believe you
just mean
at the whole situation is like i'm not
gonna change my nature right like i'm
gonna always be
kind and giving and you know objective i
just have to change
like the individuals that i spend that
time with and
that i give back all those people were
lessons for us
anything that came in your path was a
lesson so you learn from them lessons
but you can't like my mother always told
me don't change your heart
because i did when i first went to
prison i was bitter i was angry i
thought everybody
you know betrayed me but i had to learn
i betrayed myself
this is what i did to myself you know so
i took
all that time and i reflected on my life
i started learning who i who i am you
know and then so now
i walk in and i think and i know
everything that happens in your life
every day is a lesson all this everybody
in this room this is a lesson we're
getting something from everybody
you know so i try to be kind i'm trying
i'm living humility now
you know i don't i'm not bitter i'm not
angry at nobody even that
person over there might you go to the
store that tyrant that person was mean
to you that's a lesson
that's teaching me you know not to be
that person right
you know something's going on in that
person's life i read a book called the
music of life
and i was the same way right i'm bitter
i'm like man these people told on me
you know these people betrayed me this
person ain't wrote me no letters came to
visit me
and it's just one line in this book that
changed my whole perspective it says
everybody plays a role in the drama of
life
and when you think about that if i don't
go to prison shakespeare [ __ ]
right if i don't if i don't go to prison
i don't create concrete right i don't
meet rick i don't
meet joe i you know i'm saying if i
don't go to this is the most beautiful
thing that i have to contribute to the
world
um as far as legacy goes and so when i
when
when i when i read that you know
everybody plays a role in the drama
life i'm i'm i i actually became
grateful
to the people who told on me i actually
became grateful to the people who
i felt like betrayed me because
now i also realize if it wasn't for that
those steps you know what i mean then
then i wouldn't be in the shoes that i'm
in i mean i'm
sitting down with mike tyson you feel me
and sometimes it saves your life you
don't know we don't know the reason no
we don't listen
we don't know i just know this when um
when i did that three years in prison a
lot of my friends that were close to me
started dying
yeah and i always hung out with that
when you saw him you say where's mike
when he saw me he said we're here
so um everything was for a reason people
were catching aids
that i hung out with and [ __ ] girls
with
i felt that i would have died yeah that
was the reason i was in that prison and
i was again
i was understanding who i was realizing
i was never the person who i really
believed i am i was just an illusion of
myself
and i was more addicted to the illusions
of myself than i was to my reality
absolutely yeah i think i think all of
this just
even just having this conversation is
the prime example for
the individuals that's coming behind us
right you know what i'm saying i wonder
like when we drink we go out i always
say this toast you know we want to do it
bigger and better than those that came
before us
but we want to also set the tone and the
precedent for those that come after
so when you look at your story or you
look at tony's story or rick's story
my story or the story of concrete you
see
that our past doesn't define us no way
one mistake 10 mistakes 50 mistakes
we all making mistakes but we we all
first timers at life right this
is our first time no no it's our first
time that we know of right
yeah right listen but no one makes it
even important more important than that
this is very this this is very simple
this is very [ __ ] small
that me you him him
and all of us we know what happened to
us
we know why we the way we are and we
can't hide that
even though we we put on the master
saying we all know what happened to us
you know we all know what should have
happened to us because we're in a
situation where it should happen to us
and there's no secret but we all think
we hide in secrets of our pain
we all know the same pain that's why
we're in the same place right
you know but this is dope for just
people to see
and hear you know what i'm saying you
have so many people that are scarred by
the environments they grew up in and you
know especially black folks we don't
we don't go to therapy you know what i'm
saying we don't we don't talk stuff out
we do go to therapy
we listen to them
[Music]
but i think this is something that
people can listen to as well
as therapy and learn like hey just
because we went to prison just because
we
messed up in life like look at all the
beauty that we do we taking
our our very own co-creator and created
this brand from
concept to execution and it's here
it's a tangible product where you could
actually say
this is worth every penny this was made
with love and determination
and every every ingredient is specified
it took four years to build this brand
yeah but listen i'm gonna tell you
something isn't gonna make this is um
[ __ ] sad because um we're all showing
our
uh grin and what we accomplished and
we've been in prison with something
special
and then really wish [ __ ] they could
greater people have been in prison
[ __ ] right that's true though [ __ ] so
what we've been in prison
yeah great men great women been in
prison got actually
executed and they have you know and they
still were strong
you know but we're letting the people
know that we're somebody that's what's
prisoner we're still special
we can still control the world everybody
i don't care who you are in this world
you have somebody that's on drugs that
are locked up i don't care if you're the
richest
the people your families i don't care
you got somebody you love that's [ __ ]
up from society the opiates
the gun we all feel that we all feel the
pains people we lost our loved ones
everybody
people that we don't know but that
affects somebody that we love yeah they
know them and affect somebody that we
love we want to kill the person that
killed him because
the person that we love is [ __ ] up and
now we're [ __ ] up we don't even know
this [ __ ]
right right but someone we love is
[ __ ] up now yeah i just i just had to
bury my baby brother
two weeks ago two fridays ago all right
i listen right and this is something
else about people like us and i'm just
saying people in general i don't care
about black
there's people that come from where we
come there's tons of white people came
there before we got there right so
people we um in a weird way
we handle death better than lost better
than anybody ever left you know
people that come for what we because we
we anticipated we expect it because
we know what what kind of conduct is
going to get you killed
yeah you know i mean even if it's not
from the gun what's going to get you
sick out here in the streets the way you
live your life
we know that cause we've seen it over
and over again and our parents told us
what they've seen over and over it never
changes right
you know listen it's a fool this is what
i found i look at planet earth sometimes
right
and it's a fly i don't know what is a
fruit fly and it only lives for three
hours
but for three hours it has to be born it
has to absorb who he is
acknowledge who he is be a young kid be
an adolescent
get a mate mate
mate and then die right right but this
is the kid but the female lives for
three hours so take this right he's
mating
so he's going to after they made they go
to this [ __ ] what they go
[ __ ] it's so funny like 10 million and
they're flying and they're going to
[ __ ] die so they go die
and it's like 30 seconds or a minute
left and they're [ __ ] partying the
[ __ ] they slide the party they grab
they all lit up cause they light up they
all let their party and their party
their head party and finally
go light squad so they die they party
until they die
and so that the women who lived
probably five they're flying to where
they have to drop the seeds at
so they're flying so they're flying and
wherever it is they drop these [ __ ]
seas of where some [ __ ] at
or whatever manure whatever it goes it
drops the eggs
and whatever and it goes like 10 billion
of them millions and millions
and you can't believe it you can just
grab them out there so many of them and
this is the process within five hours
and now they go here and they drop their
seeds right in this water else in this
manure where nothing but [ __ ] or
something and then they die
and then it goes over and over again
because they they give they give birth
to them
they drop the seeds where they were born
at the mothers that's where they were
born so they fly and they drop the seeds
and it goes like that since the
beginning of time to now and it's going
to go on to the next beginning of the
time to the next 3
300 billion years and they know but this
is where it's tricky
brother they know their purpose in three
hours we don't live for 30 years we
don't know our [ __ ] purpose still
trying to figure it
know we out yeah yeah that would [ __ ] me
up the most they know that purpose in
three [ __ ] hours we got 30 [ __ ]
years and we don't get our purpose
so when you make that comment and say we
don't know if we live
more in just this one life so do you
think we got to keep coming
back to find our purpose no no listen
we don't got to find that purpose the
natures give us our purpose even if we
don't
you know this is our purpose if our
purpose is just to live for three years
and [ __ ] and aids and drugs and stuff
just to educate someone else just to
inspire somebody else to understand
their life
that's how i feel you know
that pain is beautiful yeah you know i
mean and death is even more glorious
than life because that's when you really
begin to live
you know we mustn't be afraid of death
we must look at death as being glorious
most of the death is going to the flies
[ __ ] party in the history of
the [ __ ] fly parties
you know gonna meet the flies
[ __ ] women in the history of
five women
fights [ __ ] the flies dope [ __ ]
besides plays the flight everybody flies
pimps everybody we gonna be dead [ __ ]
and it's the best to ever live the best
the best that that god you know i'm
talking about casper nova all these
[ __ ] they're gonna be there
right right you know and that's who i am
i'm a street [ __ ] they just have so
much determination i just
[ __ ] can't stop being a street [ __ ]
yeah you don't care how successful i get
that's just who i am
[ __ ] you know what i mean [ __ ]
i hate [ __ ] being that way but that's
who i am
that's just who i am why can't i why do
i why can't i just hate guys
why can't why do i have to say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] shut up why can't i say guys
that's not necessary guys come on let's
be nice and love every child why don't
why do i have to say [ __ ] you say to
get my [ __ ] kick in your [ __ ] head
why does it have to be there why do i
have to say that [ __ ] word because if
i don't say that i feel like you're not
you guys don't respect me that's in my
[ __ ] thick head
my street [ __ ] i think i'm around
street [ __ ] i think i'm around savages
if
they see me weak they're gonna kill me
so i gotta put that [ __ ] image of
toughness all my life you know
i'm around [ __ ] scumbags if they see
any weakness that
they can't get hurt or they may not die
or some [ __ ] like that they're going to
try you
but that's a belief system that's a
belief that's how we feel that's how
last night i said i had i mean i told
you
theresa i had to put myself on a timeout
because i
felt like that old me was about to come
out and then he was like well how was
you feeling i was
angry what did you tell me i was going
to jump but i felt like like damn who
can i
ride over there just knock this [ __ ] a
half somebody come on
you know that's how you feel this is the
game this is the date this is what i
found out too from
[ __ ] who's this [ __ ] seneca one of
these guys when someone gets you angry
they're your master
yeah yeah see that's why i took it
control your intelligence your emotions
to your master
controlling my emotions i don't want
anybody in control of my emotions
anymore
that's why i said i'ma i put myself on a
timeout because i know
if i get that angry you have control and
i don't
i mean it's a learning process to a wise
man money is a
[ __ ] tool yeah to a poor man this
money is god
yeah we talk about that also
and that's the thing and that's what we
have to learn like man this is an
illusion this is a tool
the more you give away the more you will
receive yeah it doesn't seem that way
i know you don't feel that way give it
away
you know i'm just thinking [ __ ] i don't
believe in nothing but [ __ ] and all
that stuff but [ __ ] guy gave it away
listen you gave it
listen i used to think that [ __ ] about
ain't happy angle get no [ __ ]
i gave you oh i got too many [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] right you'd be surprised what
happens when you start giving stuff away
you'd be surprised the power of
emptiness yeah
you literally i was emptying this make
more room to bring more in
you know listen don't be so attached no
no
happiness is in here there's no
happiness that doesn't exist out here
that's what we don't understand
happiness don't exist out here right
only in here the illusion of happiness
is out here
the reality of happiness is in here
that's instagram
have you when you have i mean well you
still have things
but you felt like you still i had so
much
i mean i had so much you know like i
could do whatever i wanted to do at a
time
but i still was unhappy i couldn't even
figure out like
what's making me happy who am i no you
mean tell me the house you had this door
to my house wouldn't it make you happy
hey baby for a moment for a moment it
made you happy for that second for that
moment because that's what happened this
is momentarily i used to always say
big-ass house be like damn you got a big
house it's so lovely i said but come
inside
you know and that's not saying inside
the house inside our souls inside
us you know but come inside and people
never got what i was saying
because you can see all this all this is
beautiful you have
all these people around you and you
still cannot feel the love
i feel more loved now than i have ever
felt and i don't have the riches
it's coming again because you know i
believe in me but
in a whole different way but it was i
couldn't figure out why
why wasn't i happy i go buy what i want
i can go do what i wanted to do
like you said the beautiful house she
was my neighbor you know
but come inside things don't make you
happy you know it's not about things you
know you have to find it like you said
yeah inside your children i see you and
listen
it was another young lady she was a very
attractive asian woman she was there
with your crew
and um i had met her and waited but she
got real familiar like she knew me but
we're talk
and so and then she brought me to a
house she just wanted to show me her
property she had some amazing stuff
she had some really scar face you know
with the bed and the um the tub right in
the middle of the
living room it was amazing i was just
then i found out she was a member with
the crew
but see she was just showing off she
wanted she was just showing you oh
absolutely
yeah she's not used to that she's trying
to figure out if he likes it that means
it's good
i want other people's i don't know i
have no perspective of myself i need my
i need other people to give me her
perspective
you know i don't know who i am matter of
fact i don't want to know who i am
because it's ugly i want them to tell me
i am and i want to
i want to grab that illusion and fall in
love with that illusion before i am
mm-hmm
i want to form an illusion i ain't mike
tyson that doesn't exist this [ __ ]
that's iron mike is a [ __ ] scary-ass
[ __ ]
in all reality that's why he's eyeing my
cause he's afraid
that's why he's the baddest man in the
planet because he's afraid
if that makes sense does that make sense
yeah it's like when
what what you saying like going a bully
or you press
up against you have to come out yeah
yeah you can't you gotta be serious out
here in this world and i say to myself
if i
if i was young even that might somebody
say he was the baddest [ __ ] that
ever lived in this world i said man i
don't think so
and that's just and even though he might
with my that's just the first thing i
say
you really think so [ __ ] and that's not
even him antagonizing me that's just me
saying
you really believe you are the baddest
[ __ ] out here that's with
that's that i'm i want to get my ass
kicked in
yeah i want to get [ __ ] up that's how
it is in prison though
yeah you're coming in with that tough
guy it's a dude been here 15 years i
want to get [ __ ] up
i want to get [ __ ] up and i know i
know the possibility i'm really
going to get [ __ ] because i'm who i am
now but um i just want to do this
because uh
the arrogance that his arrogance defends
my arrogance right
he's the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet and i wish i can't even believe
[ __ ] let me get away with that
hmm
that was great marketing
like in my browser they know because
this guy's just skinny enough for this
somebody said that they're the baddest
[ __ ] you gotta kill him you
gotta [ __ ] him up
he isn't gonna believe that he's 100
pounds
so why he think he could [ __ ] with this
guy 250 what the [ __ ] he's even in this
guy's face for this
i don't know but i'm scared of those
guys too
hmm wow yeah that's deep
expecting that from each other well you
can't underestimate nothing
no the champ is really to hurt everybody
a little girl everything i'm scared
um i'm the kind of guy where women hurt
you i come from where women hurt you
when you can't trust your mother
or your sister you know because it would
hurt you if you disrespected them and
you made them look bad in front of
people that's all that matters
oh [ __ ] then they go to them they'll
put the demonstration down
they'll let people know why not to [ __ ]
with them on your [ __ ] dime
that's the oil i come from i think we
all come from yeah i know yeah that's
what i'm saying that's real [ __ ] though
you try to disrespect your sister your
mother and your family they were
disrespected like you're a stranger in
the street where i come from
yeah where we come from they would make
you feel near you and say wow they don't
love me
they want to come home that's why young
kids stay out all night i was listening
i'm nine years old i'm staying out till
three in the morning [ __ ]
hanging out drinking snatching chains
snatching people's pockets out their
wallets
robbing their houses and [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] mike you were the flocker
i don't know i was breaking into the
house
i was just a [ __ ] uh i was a street
urchin
yeah anything they can do that can get
money or we were so at the low you know
you guys know black bottle
i was just a piece of [ __ ] life didn't
mean nothing my my life didn't mean
nothing to society my mother's life
didn't mean nothing my father
while life said we were those people but
with big egos
my father is a mean [ __ ]
let's talk some other [ __ ] hey listen i
got something i've been wondering
how fun was it to do the cartoon though
mike
the other night right because it come on
adult swim so i'm watching it
and he's sitting in the room with the
lawyers and the lawyers like
look she want 47 million dollars mike
tyson like
mike said when this we just got married
on friday it's monday
he said actually it's tuesday and you
just got a lump sum of 47 million
dollars
on monday he said [ __ ] i should have
came here on monday
[Laughter]
listen i'm by myself at 12 15 at night
cracking up like i'm just sitting around
with all of us i said man this [ __ ] had
to be the funnest [ __ ]
in the world to do man tell me about the
kid what's up with your kids
huh you guys have kids i do have i have
a son
cyrus maximus i got my first baby on the
way i have my first one on the way
[ __ ] yeah really oh that's because at
times
that time that came out i didn't know i
went i got i went down at 34.
so yeah and i part i live i just you
know my background
is what made me when i look at a woman
i'm like
i can either [ __ ] with her or i can i
can like really [ __ ] with her
and the girls at that time in in in
period
you had women yeah what i'm saying
but you know when i came home you know
these were some of the things i wanted
to do like i wanted to get my life in
order i wanted to
create something i wanted to create a
family and that's just where i'm at now
i'm 44.
you know what i'm saying so i'm at that
point now you know like
i got my my girl was she four months uh
in so congratulations thank you yeah
i found out i was a boy on sunday so i'm
having a son i have my sister if i can
thank you i had a kid since i came home
oh
he he's almost three yeah
congratulations yeah it's very
interesting so um
while we're in there champ we made a vow
to one another that
we would name all of our sons if we had
one
a middle name that was it was gonna be
similar so we we agreed that it was
gonna be maximus
so vincent he had his son first so his
son is
cyrus maximus i just found out that i
was having a son so his name was going
to be
jackson maximus rick was in agreeance
with such but when we're incarcerated
his brother passed away
so instead of carrying on with that his
son would be prince charles because his
brother's name was charles
and he had sickle cell so you know what
i'm saying these were all of the plans
that we had this rich sex concrete this
is stuff that we discussed in my
cell cooking this isn't coming again
yeah that's that's mike that's us in
prison that's how we did it that's a
terminal island federal prison
and we executed on everything we talked
about we walking the track we're talking
about hey this is what i'm gonna do when
i come here
we're gonna do this we all said we was
gonna do and we did it what we're doing
and we're doing it and we don't let we
don't let anyone in our circle like if
we don't know you
if you weren't in there with us beat it
he just said you know
well you're a reputable you're a whole
another level
well you have a different camaraderie
when you're in prison with you know
we call ourselves brothers when you
locked up and you come onto the streets
and you around your friends that you've
been on all your life but then you got
these guys that
you guys shared that same them same
pains and hurts and moments
all right i understand so the guy in my
room and he works with me now he's been
with me for what how long 27 years
honestly you're selling yeah yeah just
like that
you can't you can't recreate that bomb
almost it's almost like you can't live
without him even though he's not right
i'm cool he's not around me but he's
close right
very much he's gonna get here yeah his
family that's right this is what it is
i've been around um
joan rivers the old jewish comedian lady
and um she had a she had a um
assistant but the sister was a
drug out he was he had issues and stuff
and he goes disappearing every now and
then one day he just disappeared
and this never came back and everybody
was happy he was gone and she was just
devastated
and they couldn't understand what she
would definitely this guy might have
been stealing and stuff like that
and she said something to the effect of
this she said you know
when there's somebody when when you when
there's um a time when you can say hey
you remember then
remember when and the person don't not
there
it's almost over you know don't care if
you're young but that means
everything is a movement of change
because there's nobody that can remember
when
remember when we first started the goal
to get to where we are now
you know how important that is to be
with somebody when you succeed
you know because it goes so fast you
missed so many things and then you're up
there and you look around
who the [ __ ] are these people right
where are the people that you remember
when this [ __ ] first started but we
[ __ ] had to get free food or free
lunch
i had to sell some [ __ ] [ __ ] i saw
some dick with some food or some [ __ ]
and then you say [ __ ] who am i
and the next thing you know you got to
figure out who you are and then you got
to figure out if
you want to be this person and [ __ ]
you know yes this is one question that i
i i have to ask because my fiance makes
me act such
from your history of coming up when you
came up
you had um interactions with our our
current
president right now yeah and just from a
personal level
besides what our community and us what
we believe him to be
do you view him in a certain way or was
it always personal or just mad
i know him differently yeah i know him
the way that um
so wow this is gonna be interesting
conversation listen
this is the same man so you know you
know some of our leaders i'm just saying
some of our leaders um says he's
disguised this way
but these are some of the same people
who are witnessing my eyes came to all
of his
um conventions and he was they were all
comped
you know i don't want to mention the
name but the people are saying that he's
dead
no listen i'm really good friends with
him and know him at the level where they
could talk [ __ ] to him and discipline
stuff
and their friends like that but now they
got a chance to do it while he's on a
big world stage
and they don't really mean that they
like him but they can say that to him
from a friendly from what they used to
be like and
it's mad they're not in a circle they
can't be his friend again they want to
be in his
circle now but they're not in a circle
no more they're not able to go up to him
at any time and call them or shake their
hand no more he's unaccessible to them
so that makes them feel a little bit
less important to our ego
i can see that i could see somebody that
we always could talk [ __ ] listen
listen listen yeah
listen no i know people who used to
sleep on the floor and stuff
they started hooking some of the stuff
they became building and big stuff right
and um we still talk to them the way we
talk to them like he and he stepped on
this on the bus
on the couch and that's how these people
do the donald trump
you know donald trump was a regular guy
everybody was friendly with him he was
very social he knew everybody
and he he knew guys that um that was
egos and had a lot of money and stuff
and has more money than him
and he's pregnant president and they're
hating on him now
these are his friends they're all in the
same circle they all hung out together
they probably went to the same school
again they all know each other very well
like mueller and trump went to the same
school they went all these guys went to
the same rich
exotic school together and this is just
a journal c showing they get jealous too
billionaires get jealous too because it
won't be about the money yeah
it'd be about who you are yeah
it's very easy listen it's very easy to
be jealous with him too
he's really arrogant so it's very easy
to be jealous with him but they're
jealous
just put it out to their jokes way
successful than me money-wise
but they didn't have my energy they
didn't have to drive they didn't have my
vibes you know what i'm saying
right they would be mad about those
things and
it's just what it is that's just how i
look if i look at life different since
they're told before everything [ __ ] all
them [ __ ] suck my dick [ __ ] i'm tyson
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] hoe [ __ ] i
got look at my yeah that's a [ __ ]
clown that's my insecurity my jealousy
my shame and all that [ __ ] damn i miss
that tyson right here
no no listen listen yeah
everybody missed that but now they have
to see that i have to realize that um
that was the wrong way of living yeah
like go wrong
yeah that was the wrong way of living
but i'm gonna i'm gonna prove that the
wrong way because i'm live totally the
opposite now
yeah yeah you have to go through there
to get here i would never get here if i
didn't go through that
what you went through you encouraged us
so much like when we were we do tons of
podcasts we've been an entrepreneur fast
company i often let vincent come
when he said we was going to i'm
stopping everything i'm no more meetings
the champ is here and you just mean so
much to us man
but you met me at the right time on my
life man yeah yeah you read me at the
right thing
sometimes in my life i was saying who
are you what do you [ __ ] want right
who you to meet me how did you get into
my presence right some [ __ ] [ __ ]
because i'm uncomfortable with myself
right and when you're uncomfortable with
yourself having no self-love you show it
by
striking out on other people and other
things it's crazy i read one quote i
don't know it's an anonymous
author but he said the first person to
raise his hand
in violence is the first man to run out
of ideas
absolutely and i never wanted to be that
man that's what happens when you start
cursing that's because you ran out of
like you ran out of ideas on how to
express yourself yes
what you're saying [ __ ] you [ __ ]
that's me i said [ __ ] it
i gotta be right i have to come to this
for me i gotta go like this like if i'm
doing anything
this is a [ __ ] tony robbins yeah
[Laughter]
because this is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] black
people getting locked up and doing long
time for [ __ ]
minor cases that [ __ ] probation
for
this is that's this is [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
would you allow
any of your children to fight
professionally
no no no no no no no no what they're
gonna what what a [ __ ] like this they
got
color television rolls royces [ __ ]
for what
fiction no no no no no he has all this
[ __ ] but he he wants to prove to his
father i'm somebody and stuff
and then he fights somebody like me that
has nothing
never will have nothing unless i hurt
people
how's he gonna do wow he get hit with a
hard [ __ ] right hand
oh that [ __ ] hurts i'm gonna get this
mansion to go back to i live in
newport beach i got this man [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
he gets hit with a hard punch [ __ ]
bringing [ __ ] i got a lot of [ __ ] worth
to go to yeah
you know i gotta go back home
[ __ ] shoot straight bullets
coming through my window i might hit my
loser i might have lost my sister or my
mother or something that's what i'm
going back to
even though i lost him nothing's changed
no one felt sorry for me and got me a
new house i mean
no i'm gonna get it still go both gonna
still come through that no one gives a
[ __ ]
that weed fire cause mike going in today
very much
no because that's who i am that's where
i'm from that's why i know that's so
[ __ ] well
any first time dad advice that you can
give for us being first-time fathers
like that you would
give someone if it was just one thing or
that i'm your shitty dad
you ain't [ __ ] what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do come on tell me
what are you gonna do i mean i'm just
what are you gonna do you got a baby
he's not right now he's be his mother
he's on his mother's titty what are you
doing what are you gonna do
this is you all right what do you need i
just like you said a shitty father their
support like actually when you say what
are you gonna do
yeah really this is what we do this is
um you know what happens with our
children
our children are mistakes and our
grandchildren are perfection
that's real [ __ ] yeah yeah
i don't i don't know if my son's a
mistake
they had a mistake on our perception of
them yeah
what you think that you could do for
them and make them a better person
and without if it's not you they're not
gonna be good right
thinking if i'm not in that life they're
gonna be shitty they're gonna be
probably gay they're gonna be [ __ ] up
they're not gonna be the way you think
they should be so they're gonna be
[ __ ] up
i know one thing i know i grew up in
foster homes and all type of stuff you
do
like i have the opportunity now to
control the narrative to say okay
me the things that i i didn't have
growing up or the
the what i can do is i can provide those
things to my child
and give them the opportunities that i
always wanted to have but i just didn't
have i'm gonna tell you something dude
you're first father's right
yeah yeah oh i'm gonna blow your mind
right you love these kids you love your
baby huh
you love your baby right yeah he's gonna
get a certain day and you gotta hate him
tell him elaborate more huh
listen to school you took care of him
you took her
you sent him to school he gave a
beautiful roof over his head gave him a
great mother gave him great family and
one day he's going to say [ __ ] you
yeah it's coming [ __ ] who the [ __ ] you
think you a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] dad [ __ ] you i'm about to whoop
your way
hold up yeah yeah i know that's already
cool your master now now
now you're not the teacher now you're
the student right listen when my son
my son looked at me right one day oh
it's coming he like six months old
i said no these my titties he looked at
me and was like
yeah all right i see
y'all i already know he coming for them
for my spot
i have a nine year old son he's in
competition with me before my [ __ ]
wife
and he's not either but i know where
this goes so i think this is really
interesting so i always say things that
we're together and she said he go like
this
i'm coming to sleep with you and i say
baby tell that [ __ ] that this is my
[ __ ] you're my wife you guys to tell
his mother because he does it too
[ __ ] much
he's always like trumping me almost like
if he was a man if he was if he was a
teenager he'd be bitching me
if he was the [ __ ] the [ __ ] that he said
like if i'm saying something my wife has
a baby can you please give me some
he said why don't you get it he's nine
years old
no he's fascinated with his mother he's
totally in love with the [ __ ]
it's not that
fascinating i have three sons i do so
and then and it's different it's a
different love i don't know they just so
tell them fascinating why can't
if you had a it's just it's just it's a
different type of love
you know y'all he won't call me to say
daddy i'm hungry i need my food he'll
call his mother his mother
anything we're in the middle of a
[ __ ] photo shoot we're in the
middle of traffic we gotta pull up she's
calling him to say what you need i'm
giving him like he that's a baby you're
going to make him
he can't beat him he got to get his ass
he got to hear the word no he got the
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] get your
own [ __ ] you got to hear that [ __ ] baby
yeah you do as i got they got older i
realized that
yeah that you have to be like that's the
mistakes i did
yeah in my earlier life so i know i have
to explain to them even though they're
young like
cos explain to me that you have to learn
from your mother or father watch us
because we're not going to be here long
in your life
and we're not going to be handing what
we teach you you're going to have to
learn you'll learn more in life as we go
and then you can teach your children
and you can tell them what we taught you
and they'll learn even more than we
could ever teach you
because they'll learn more than what you
could teach them because as time goes by
we'll find out secrets that we never
knew when we were alive about the world
and you got to explain that to them even
though they explained it to me they get
tired of hearing it and then they
explain that to
the next thing though they could explain
it to you what you've been telling them
just keep saying it mm-hmm
you know you gotta let them explore
your children don't belong to you yeah
we think that's our ego
they don't belong to you they belong to
the future why are you
saying that child to the future it's
wild that's where we can go
that's the place we can go roy said that
as we're coming of age
that our first love being a male is your
mother yeah
and your first love being a female is
your father
so that is their first love so when i'm
when i study that and i'm listening to
what you're telling me i'm like that is
really true
no listen you have a woman a wife
yes the only reason you have a concern
about her reminds you of your mother
that's the only
[Music]
he wouldn't be with her see listen peep
game
i'ma let you know just like me my life
hey i'm getting personal yeah yeah
seriously
listen listen if she wasn't like your
mother you wouldn't take the [ __ ] that
she
[ __ ] did you think that's so [ __ ]
crazy the [ __ ] that he said oh she ain't
raising money if she wasn't like her you
wouldn't take that
if my mother my wife wasn't like my
mother wouldn't take the [ __ ] she'd do
counseling session the champ and mr
coley with this session
yeah no it's not that i have a bad
relationship with my mom but
my mom really liked growing up she
wasn't really there like that you know
what i'm saying no no no no listen
it's just like a woman you can't get her
to pay attention to you
yeah i want her to pay attention to me i
want the whole man love me like she does
that man that i don't know yeah
and that's all we ever want especially
you know like you said
moms is our first love if my mom can't
let me how can another [ __ ] love me she
gave me she brought me in this world
women like yeah well absolutely that's
their comfortable zone yeah
our ego keeps us in our comfort zone so
we won't get hurt
isn't that something sometimes we allow
our egos to lie to us we don't want
nothing like our mother
my mother my mother from a personal
perspective is a disaster
but it's something about her loving and
caring that's hidden that no one can see
that we're trying to get
i know one thing though i can say they
got in common that i can think of
a complexion
[Laughter]
you know why we laughing because um
we even brothers men whatever
we allow men to even fool us
that woman can't be girl she can give
birth to us but she can't be god huh
we are our mother and then we become
like our father but we're our mother
because we've been nurtured for nine
months in there and
everything about our father is pretty
much gone and if we do got something
about our fathers there it's because the
process didn't go right because it's all
about our mother that's who we are
that's why we keep finding her we're
looking for her in other [ __ ]
we look for her in [ __ ] hoes [ __ ]
that we don't even [ __ ] would never
want to be seen with in public if that's
my mother i need her so that's why you
think man got women issues too then oh
absolutely
because this is the person i love but i
don't know this is the person i love but
i don't like her reputation
yeah i can't do without her reputation
as [ __ ] but i can't
i can't leave her either
i'd rather be with her in a horrible
reputation to be with the most
precious and prosting people in the
world
this is true love and the true love is
something we can't control even that's
why we get mad at our wives or husbands
i'm like
we love this [ __ ] you ever
thought that i love this [ __ ]
yeah i believe i love this [ __ ]
he gave me some [ __ ] this [ __ ]
wish he was dead but i love this
[ __ ]
i'll kill this [ __ ] i love this
[ __ ]
and then you realize you're doing all
this [ __ ] because she has so much
control you ain't killing nothing [ __ ]
but you're [ __ ] passionate about
loving her
you know you can't live without a high
i'm gonna kill her so that's when you
make love to you try to kill her
listen it's all killing it's the
perception of killing the
passion is dying so i don't want to feel
that feeling now it's gone
thank god i love you thank you baby
everything was an illusion hug
leaving you you leaving her the kids
getting broke up sending half the hug
changing banks account and now you
[ __ ] in
that's all [ __ ] uh illusion that [ __ ]
ain't gonna happen my reality is that i
love her and she loves me and we're
gonna
live together with these kids for the
rest of our life but that [ __ ] whole
illusion that we build up that [ __ ]
she's gotta be mad [ __ ] i know she's
looking at that guy like the way she was
with this guy
i love you baby
[Laughter]
that's what it boiled down to uh in the
end huh
but most of us are turmoil most of us
are made out of turmoil yeah
and we have to receive peace and that's
why i created a lot of love
so it can help bring the love back
together so it can help bring the spice
back
where can people find this man yeah
where can people find this stuff
oh reset www
richsexco.com baby which sex i like rich
it's a great name man rich sex and
concrete we work together we help with
marketing we just
like if this is my project i would say
politic pounding or something like that
authentic pounding what are you doing
with black people you get black people
from the ghetto over here this is [ __ ]
goes on right
that's awesome from the ghetto who
superseded all their expectations
absolutely absolutely let me have to put
that out we're from together but we
superseded all our expectations from
people that are from the ghetto
yeah it's awesome
say that again tony so just to wrap up
and let everybody know you know what you
guys want people to leave with about
concrete
we're with one of the we partnered with
one of the largest
pr marketing company in the united
states not all over the world
72 and sunny so they believed in us so
much that they wanted
to be doing sunny 72 and sunny they
believed in us so much that they
partnered with us
so we are on the move we're doing great
things we're helping a lot of people i
believe in young guys tyson rats believe
what can i do to be involved
i think the easiest thing that we would
like people to leave from because we got
two kind of demographics right
we're looking at people who have been
through what we've been through formerly
incarcerated creatives
incarcerated people who are creative to
actually join our movement so we can
actually enter them into this space you
know i have people who i love that i've
been visiting for like 17 years man
listen um and they're just my family i
just have to do the bid with them
because it's like me like
it's weird you're seeing somebody that
you love in there isn't that a [ __ ]
for that you're used to being outside
you know it's 20 years 25 years 28 years
ago you're like looking at him
and you one guy he doesn't change it all
one guy he's losing it a little
you know how long has it been for him
twenty-eight [ __ ] like yeah yeah
but this one guy hey but this one guy
ain't losing nothing stayed
everything but he a little
blessing reach and touch no it's not
what it is exactly but i'm gonna tell
you something let's go blow your mind
because we're praising people
have you ever been when you locked up
something where it was a guy just doing
this time and it was just beautiful
doing his time he was happy
and you say to myself you get mad why
this [ __ ] got a life double life
you got triple lights you know who's the
best that did the time like that quietly
was another chap michael nunn he was in
federal prison
fighter the fighter yeah he did his time
just like that like i just wanted he he
was like a yoda to me i was like
this is interesting because when mike
was a fighter the mic with bad
energy you did like mike was back and i
come from brownsville so i know bad no
trouble
yeah bad [ __ ] he was bad [ __ ] he's
always looking to beat people even
playing dice
he's always listening to bully people
intimidate them and um
i'm so happy that he finds himself and
sometimes
people find their kingdom in there yes
they find their world in there this is
not for them this world is not for
everybody this is
to some people this is not living this
is a this is a dead life
out here you know i can't let nobody
know i'm magnificent i got talent i'm
the greatest fight but no one's still
listening to me
my fighting which i think is my
deliverance but it's not
this is my deliverance more people
listen to me in here than out here
you know that's what we want to do is be
listened to hurt
well you went there you really don't
stress no there's nothing stressed about
you
stress you know you're working you're
working out you've got your mind
reading [ __ ] some of the things like i
like sometimes i can just take um
inventory of my life at
this point in time and i can be sitting
there and not be like man i'm not at my
best because i was at my best
when i was locked up and it's foolish
my mind was clear i was reading books
every day yeah and i come out here
and you know i'm i'm moving forward but
like i said
if i had that same energy yeah and and i
can just take it with me right now
i would be so much further because the
discipline
yeah you get out here you get you know
when you come home
you kind of stray a little bit and then
you got to put it back together you know
what i mean
and yeah move forward so no doubt maybe
the first year i was stranded
you know what i'm saying and i was like
you know what okay look i got another's
enough i got a plan
it's all about not being discouraged
yeah listen i've been knocked out beat
up as a kid a younger fighter and stuff
people have been saying i just knew
never to get discouraged i
knew i would get my day if i continue to
try hard and believe in myself
i didn't that i felt lost i didn't have
to act like i didn't because i fight him
again
i fight him like i knocked him out the
first time it's all about what you
believe you know
and i'm and when you think about me i'm
a nothing guy i'm really nothing that's
something that's nothing not educated
guy but i used to
i got belief in myself and belief is
more powerful than anything
confidence applied properly with
superseded genius
yeah i think that's the biggest biggest
thing for concretes
i heard 2200 no's
where i tried to get investors i went to
different incubators and accelerated
people
told me note that there was no money
in the incarcerated population
and i believed in this thing so much
that i funded it
out of my own pocket and pushed the line
and now we're a global global brand
awesome
just like you like you explain what they
did for a living whatever they did and
that was their
i look at this thing my best point was
that i was born from pimps and
prostitutes
because i look at myself i say i know
i'm beautiful it's something that he
wants from me i have the same concept
it's something that he wants for me you
know because if i looked at me
i'm beautiful i know it's something i
would want from me right
you know to be associated with let me
introduce him to some of my friends my
girlfriend stuff like that
and it's just a concept it's not that
it's true but it's my belief in my mind
that i'm
i'm beautiful and now i'm sexy and that
i i project that to you
you want to get [ __ ] with this and
it's all sexual my whole life is a
sexual thing
you know but i i tried to i tried to not
believe that but that's why
i was born from that world right yeah me
too
your appearance is everything your
parents just your parents
right you know what i mean i don't have
[ __ ] to go to but i look beautiful my
the place i go to is going to be like a
[ __ ] where
you can smell [ __ ] and dogs still come
in and [ __ ] but i look beautiful
you know people's perception of you like
i was explaining earlier earlier
to someone that was here um you look at
a cop that's his uniform you look at the
dope dealer and
in the corner that's the uniform there
they're called the way
pimps that's their uniform it tells you
who they are the way we identify
they identify with that title so it's
like for a long time i'm like all i'ma
ever be is a drug dealer you know what
i'm saying or
a jacker or whatever you know what i'm
saying so you you start to identify with
that
that that uniform you're talking about
you know yeah and listen this is
something you're not gonna know this
you are that person and you're still
that person and you're meeting person
that you never think is like you but
he's like you and that's why you got in
business with him because deep down
inside he's like you he's been to you
but you just don't know his life you
don't know what happened to him
you see most of those guys listen um in
detroit
most of those guys that was in politics
and senators governors and stuff
they were gangsters too they had a
little white gang they had that italian
irish gang the greek gang you had comey
and they had they came these are people
from our neighborhood and we're doing
good now so why i'm going to let them do
bad
right when i was doing bad they were
feeding me so now i'm doing good i'm
gonna feed them that's just something
neat
oh that's just what you do in the
community i'm the kind of guy like that
i miss that kind of guy he's looking out
for these guys keep these guys fed
keep dignity let their family respect
them their kids and their wives respect
them and i have to say about that ain't
[ __ ]
but this [ __ ] shouldn't say this
nigga's better than him and all that
[ __ ]
we all keep our dignity in pride we take
care of one another
almost like a communist community so to
speak
let me clear that up people might get
offended when you say coma young but he
was our hero
oh absolutely he was a great man hey
listen um
cared about his community let me explain
something about greatness
we we admire greatness we worship almost
greatness
but greatness doesn't mean goodness
most of the most i've met a lot of great
people
and most of them weren't good people so
i decided i want to be a good person
yeah
and greatness doesn't mean [ __ ] to me my
greatness shows by my goodness
and i and i decide i just want to always
be kind
you know that's my time is good too
that's what we have the kind festival
we believe just be kind you know and i
hashtag
be kind all the time my wife's always
saying it's easier
it's just easier it's you know but
sometimes
by not being kind
we um sometimes evoke things from people
that would never be evoked from them
if you were kind to them if you ignite
their
personality you offend their ego they
might come up with something that
saves the world something is it's a
saying a belief in system or something
people have to be tested without
struggle there's no progress
we can't be safe we can't feel sorry for
ourselves stop feeling sorry for our
feelings
he hurts his feelings [ __ ] your feelings
life is about surviving
we can live life is not time is life is
not sure time is not short
it's how you use the time to make it
wrong
life is short when we do nothing when we
do nothing like for sure when we sit in
an afternoon our life is short
when we um when we're [ __ ] uh
illuminating our mind life is [ __ ]
long
isn't it you know you're being one of
those sports when you're working your
mind is [ __ ]
you know that six hours went by ten
hours went by yeah then time is long and
it's pro
and it's productive too right doing
nothing non-productive and it's [ __ ]
short
but it seems long because we're doing
nothing but it's over
and nothing's been done nothing been
done but waste of time yeah
no we can't to do something we can't do
something for the people
you know this is like i said a kind
gesture i think for me
one of the things that was crazy is when
i got sentenced
the judge basically said that i didn't
have any victims
that my victim was society and i got to
prison and i thought about that like
i've seen you know like if you kill
someone they have
programs that allow you to reconcile
with
your victims i thought how can how can i
actually
rectify what i've done to society do you
do you know what
the society of those people think of a
drug deal or what a drug dealer is
oh yeah your uh your uh what was that
gum of the earth no no no no they got
their words for it
okay what is that word what did hitler
do
what's that word hitler did it's a crime
against humanity no
what that too but what did he do uh
what's it terminate exterminate that's
exterminating communities
because the whole bunch of [ __ ] and
puerto ricans they think are
that's what he told me he said yo we
know with your drugs
your drugs bring guns and your guns
bring
violence and we all know what drugs and
guns have done to the city of youngstown
now mind you i've been in ohio yeah
training camp there really you know cats
in ohio think they could fight
that's a lot of football coaches coming
out of there young got a bunch of world
champion fighters
and young time is really a gangster huh
it's a mob
that's where the big mobs go they give
the decision to the guys in the big
cities
yeah interesting and they send their
money to the ohio and other
michigan ohio little towns in michigan
not the big ones either those are the
bosses because they know how to keep
quiet and nobody knows who they are
i say you act like i [ __ ] up
youngstown like this [ __ ]
been [ __ ] up how did you giant
how did you come to rectify that for
yourself well
i think what i was trying to say was
like concrete is my
my rectification this is my ability to
have the men and women that i represent
and serve
actually contribute to society in in a
productive manner that
that um i feel is is essentially the
same concept
right but but now we're fueling the
economy now we're giving out jobs now
we're giving people a second chance when
they get out of prison
to to to be what we consider productive
members of society
and so you know to me that's my mission
is to it's directly pretty much the same
thing i do like most of
this is gonna you know no matter of fact
we're um
we got a business with british tobacco
american british tobacco and my thing is
to give all my money back to the
community
you know what i mean if i could if i if
i have the balls because i'm such a
materialistic pig right
if i have the balls to give all that
money back and have not take nothing let
my wife and them do whatever they want
there but you think my happiness do what
i want
i would think i would be somebody i
would be somebody about the guts to get
rid of that money
normally when i would use that money to
take advantage of people use it to
make mics my ego yeah
and then think about giving it away
people after the show
i don't even [ __ ] like you know you
give away the [ __ ] you always
despise
that's the greatness and you want to
give it away because that's the goodness
i wouldn't have done this at 30 no 35
or 38 or 40. it's ready for me to do it
now
yeah it's awesome
so can i can i shout out the website
please please
tell us where to find you maybe right
here let them know so
concrete.com that's c-o-n-c-r-e-a-t-e-s
dot com um on all social media platforms
it's concrete
cre the number i'm sorry yeah the number
eight
tes at cre
the number eight tes awesome
that's just so awesome man it's true
magazine
fast company magazine whatever it is
wise ad week
all right a lot of great a lot of great
pub on you guys man
you're doing great work i mean it's
awesome
me personally no my ig my ig is miss
tonissa love cause i'm all about love so
it's m-s-t-o-n-e-s
a-l-o-v-e love miss tony love and
greatness
love and grace and when you guys are
saying that maximus stuff i would say
wow that is so crazy because my um
[ __ ] um
my [ __ ] i was that the other person
you are you're subbies
[ __ ] mac i'm [ __ ] mega maximus
mike
of course dude yeah [ __ ] i say that to
myself every day at home and this i'm
this guy and this guy does this and that
and
i love it and [ __ ] and then i come out
to reality get the [ __ ] away from me
uh rich sex co um r-i-c-h protect your
wealth baby
yes and i learned today by these old
greek [ __ ] at 414 bc that
wealth is not [ __ ] money what is your
happiness
peace of mind joe that's your wealth
um money's just money joe michael
concreates dot com that's not email
that's my email
what's that no yeah you got it yeah you
have to work with me i just came home i
i've been gone i've been going for 17
years five months and they they
i just came home and they have me on the
cover of magazines i'm here i'm i'm
getting back acclimated i don't even
know how to turn on my phone
just work with it
about this you know that's the part that
i used to like like you know
it's funny with laughing but listen like
he is lost um
you know how much um that time you know
how much life he
[ __ ] time how much life he loved yeah
yeah
that's a whole high school kid that's
that's himself
that's a man that's a 17 year old man a
woman yeah that can give birth
raise the family yeah very much
well you guys are doing incredible
things man we appreciate that
i want to be involved and do something
too that's cool that's cool
absolutely that's it we're saying it
right here on the joint
we finna cook with mike tyson that's it
we gotta do things like [ __ ] like we
do we do like um
golf [ __ ] uh tournaments and stuff
cooking tournaments
oh yeah we got a cooking show yeah we
got a cooking show
all right this is what we're cooking
else we have gathers but we're getting
ready to have a gallery where we get
ready to get black tied in a few minutes
ago
things are happening okay well let's get
it god is great let's
do it let's get it got it right well
guys thank you so much
vince rick joe tony thank you so much
for joining us today
yes thank you love you pleasure
appreciate that
hey everybody thanks for watching this
episode of hot boxing
until next time i'm evan and i'm mike
tyson and it's over
protecting no more interviews
[Music]
you